hello everybody it's gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode three three 36 26
that was think of us at 326 of the
askgaryvee show
I'm super excited to have tillman
Partida here with me I'm gonna let him
introduce himself but we were taking
questions on Facebook today and so let's
just get right into it tilman thank you
for being on hey it's exciting to be
here Gary uh everybody wants to come and
be on the Gary Vee show so tell me what
for for the group that's watching right
now or listening that doesn't know who
you are I'm a big fan of the origin
story so why don't you why don't you
tell everybody hey what you currently
how you currently position yourself
because one thing I adore about you from
afar is you got your hands on a lot of
different stuff it's that kind of
entrepreneurial mindset I can attest to
that I understand it so when somebody
says somebody meets sits down with you
and says you know and doesn't know who
you are they're like what do you do how
do you answer it
that's really funny that doesn't happen
that often but when it does I just say
you know I'm I'm just trying to make a
few dollars I have a few little
businesses and you know my main business
is a company called Landry's it's about
600 restaurants and Landry's owns
everything from from Mastro's to
Martin's to rainforests to Bubba Gump to
salt grass to ocean air to Dos Caminos
to Bill's burgers and on and on and on
there's like 50 branch 5:05 yeah about
50 brands and over 500 restaurants but
and then the five Golden Nugget casinos
are mine and then and aquarium's
amusement parks catch and then I'll have
this little sports team called the
Houston Rockets and I do that on the
side when I'm not busy was was uh so
let's take it all the way back where
were you born what kind of kid were you
I was born in Galveston Texas
it's a bo I and I was I was never the
smartest kid in the class I can honestly
tell you that and I can remember a
teacher telling me once you know mister
Teta we know you have leadership
abilities but a curio mostly we know you
have leadership ability mr. Fertitta but
we wish you would lead in the right
direction I don't know how bad you were
at school but this is probably my pride
and joy my report card
it's pretty [ __ ] ugly it is uh it is
uh it's a doozy as you're getting your
glasses why don't I oh there you go I've
got to see these grades to see who was
worse
me or you mm-hmm this looks like one of
mine and third grade school you know
what I am going to look at my glass rank
I'm going down there to 40 fall away at
the bottom to 43 out of 254 there were
only 11 kids in my school that were
worse than me and there's no shot any of
the 11 of them are alive that is so good
I just love this because I wasn't far
behind and and and that's what's amazing
is I've talked to entrepreneurs we're
given a different ability and and it's a
it's a god-given ability and we just
know how to do it yes and knowing that
you've been around sport you know do you
view entrepreneurs like athletes that
way like James Harden was given a gift
that's obvious to a lot of people it's a
little less obvious where you're going
with this on the entrepreneurial kick
but I couldn't agree with you more
Gary I talk about it all the time I talk
about it in this book that that God gave
us all an ability and he decided Tillman
I'm not gonna make you a musician
because I took guitar lessons for four
years and I still couldn't play a chord
I'm not gonna let you win a Grammy I'm
not gonna let you win an Emmy we're sure
not gonna never let you be an NBA
all-star or be a professional athlete
but you know what we're gonna do we're
gonna give you a good little business
brain where you know how to make money
and I realized that when I was in
elementary school I would carry my
business around I wouldn't I wouldn't
have I wouldn't read a comic book or do
anything I was selling candy and
anything else I could buy and sell in
junior high and high school I was
already trading the stock market and in
college I was a business I was already
putting bets
get it was the family like what did your
parents my dad on the seafood restaurant
when I was growing up and was an
entrepreneur and there's lots of
entrepreneurs in our family genetic pool
on both sides that's cool
and and and so I definitely it's a gene
yes no question without a doubt no
question and and but I can remember my
dad though after I had my fifth
restaurant and I was making a couple of
million dollars a year saying why do you
want to do any more I mean you're made
you hate it you have limited living by
the way when I helped build my dad's one
wine store into a national ecommerce
player in the late 90s and everybody in
my high school and my friend group said
I'd made it and and I remember like when
they would say that to me at 28 29 30
and I left at 34 it was a family
business I built it from a three to a
sixty million dollar business and then I
left started at zero because it was my
dad's business and that's what I wanted
to do I wanted to give back to my dad I
was born in the Soviet Union I was very
proud and grateful for what my parents
did for me but at 29 30 31 my friends
were like you made it right because they
would read the articles they would hear
the numbers and I used to laugh I'm like
they don't even know that I'm about to
restart from zero totally made it like
by the way I feel like I haven't [ __ ]
started right now I get up every day and
it's kind of funny and I'm a little
older than you and it's just sport and
you know just when I was 21 I won my
first Cadillac selling Shaklee vitamins
I said when I'm 35 I'm gonna buy my
first jet I did and you know on and on
there's a cushion have you thought about
tangible things like were you that kind
of like like for example it doesn't come
natural to this day I don't want I want
to buy the New York Jets
so you've accomplished something I want
to do right but I don't want anything
else in between but were you somebody
who wanted stuff like Cadillac Jets were
like you were like you like that [ __ ] or
you thought it meant something I'm just
curious how your brain were no no
totally I mean I had in my brain that
this is what I want and I'm gonna try to
get from point A to point B however I
have to do it and I hope you're not in
the way because I have to run over your
ass okay but but but I wanted the
Cadillac I wanted
the the deep question deep do you think
you wanted that to show the people that
thought you were not gonna win that you
were winning as an indicator I think
about this a lot I don't have this great
need to like show anybody I actually
it's unbelievable to me how much I don't
give a [ __ ] if they know if I'm winning
or not I'm just obsessed with the
process however there are many other
things I have I'm just always curious
with ones that go along the way cuz
we're all different in our nuances I'm
always fascinated by what did those
things represent was it people some
people just like stuff like I'm
fascinated by people who love a car or a
jet they understand it they're like it's
got the horsepower and I'm like what the
[ __ ] right and there's other people who
need it to be like I'm gonna [ __ ]
show Susan Thompson and third grade who
didn't go to the dance with me that she
[ __ ] up no I think it was more of the
luxury and and you know how I wanted to
live I don't I don't I never had that
mentor and I also never had that I need
to show you so it was more in
competitiveness with myself and how I
wanted to live yeah and you know I'm
proud that I've never gone through a TSA
line okay and what's crazy about that
this is what I love about this [ __ ] to
me
and on the flip side I put out so much
content of me being at the airport like
I on the flip side love that I limit my
private travel and we're doing the same
thing we're both putting something that
we've subjectively decided is important
on a pedestal
no 100% yeah it's interesting yeah I
mean every day I'm like I'm such a
[ __ ] idiot time is the only asset and
I'm [ __ ] putzing around on like
[ __ ] you know commercial but then I'm
like [ __ ] so many people are watching
they get so much visuals around private
and all this stuff and like I'm still
plottable like this I like and it's a
very interesting thing that I played
ping-pong in my head no cuz you know
even so many close friends I'm Adam have
always said to me are you ever gonna
take me on one of your jets I've known
you for all these years I don't do
anything to show off it is strictly I
believe you this is the way I want to
live I believe okay it's all about how
you
live what's the what's the what's the
weirdest thing what's the least
efficient thing you do that is around
how you want to live like what's
something that's silly like like I think
me flying commercials silly it's not a
good use of my time but it's how I want
to live so I understand it what is
something funny that you do that doesn't
make sense probably you know I love
being in Monte Carlo on my yacht but
going shopping and Zara and coming back
to my boat and laying out to all of my
crew that look what I look at all these
jackets I just bought how gorgeous they
are for $18.99 euros each that I had six
gorgeous jackets that I only spent a
hundred and thirty euros on and I was so
proud of myself I couldn't wait to show
my crew that's what I'm proud of yes
even though I like these nice things I
love to make a deal and and in love to
spend money and what I like I'll spend
money on the big things that I watch how
I spend it on the little things I
understand I really do so how did your
career go what you know you sold some
stuff you want a Cadillac you're a good
salesman gift of gab charisma I get you
know conviction you know right
determination I understand all that [ __ ]
where because your dad had a seafood
restaurant did you work in that seafood
restaurant as a kid yeah 100% learn aft
so uh I learned how the restaurant
business worked yeah okay then you go to
school you get out and I got into the
development business was building homes
got into the video game business the
pac-man asteroids talk to me that I just
timed it right you know I need I don't
know this I don't know I don't know a
lot about anything so that's why I love
having these things what did you bet
that back remember back in the 80s you
had asteroids that came out and it was
the first real video game and then but
then became defender and pac-man and all
of those well I saw that the world was
changing and so I went out and bought
these machines and started putting them
in restaurants around and all of a
sudden you're you know I look up and I'm
making hundreds of thousands of dollars
in cash right you're right and are you
literally driving your Cadillac around
grabbing buckets of [ __ ] quarters no
but I was I went out you know probably
in the first you know I can't remember
but now eventually we had a few trucks
divorce and all I remembered I mean all
these big bags of quarters and you know
and it was all I know is I was I was in
high cotton I was feeling really good
about myself
and did that for a few years which gave
me the opportunity to start building
homes and little shopping centers and
then I built my first hotel when I was
26 years old in my hometown which I
still own today and and and that and
that's kind of the story and then the
development business came apart all the
banks failed and in the late 80s this is
a great story and I talked about it in
the book I had loans at like nine
different banks in the late 80s in Texas
and that's when this crisis was as bad
as the Oh II don't I thought it was that
was the the world came apart yep every
bank that I did business with failed
before I did and so uh there's two
million worth of loans which was a bunch
of money in the 80s okay yeah there was
nobody to pay all of a sudden you have
to make a payment and there's nobody to
make a payment to the bank is gone the
FDIC has shut them [ __ ] down
okay tell me real quick cuz I want you
to go back to point please tell the kids
here how much to million dollars give me
a number of the way you feel two million
dollars in eighty seven
what's that equivalent to right now I
would probably say twenty million you
know it would be like heaven 20 million
he's always talking about when you know
I apologize you know how I always tell
my audience I'm like you know my
transcending moment my career was when I
was right about YouTube but I didn't
invest in it and then I read when
YouTube sold for 1.7 billion dollars to
Google I don't if you remember this or
anybody else in the room that sounded
like a trillion it was a step now like
companies that don't make any money are
worth a billion but at the time YouTube
so there's only two thousand seven 1.7
billion well it shook me
it's a crazy number time and I'll give
you an example of something so so so
basically what happened is I got a
reprieve from the governor okay and so
all of a sudden I had five years to keep
growing my business before the FDIC
called me it said mister for Tita we
have some loans here we would like
to talk to you about but by then I had
opened up a bunch of restaurants made a
bunch of money I walked in and paid the
fdic two million dollars they waived all
the interest and they said you were the
only person to pay us in full but I was
rolling then and so things were good do
you want to wait till that thing goes
with [ __ ] so so you know it's so in
1982 I bought into the Rockets for
$200,000 wait I didn't know that we pay
ten million dollars for the Houston
Rockets in 1982 but you got 20% no two
million
no no no I was just on the small percent
okay one more time in here to $200,000
twenty percent would have been two
million I got it so I think but we also
had some debt on it I think I owned like
three or four percent okay whatever it
was okay so I'm a partner in the Rockets
for ten years the owner decides to sell
the general partner says this was
becoming a billionaires game well this
is in 1992 and I'm only worth about ten
fifteen million dollars that's don't get
me wrong that's a bunch of money okay
Jochen so I try to buy I didn't have the
ability to buy the team by myself
so I had a partner and we tried to buy
it and I got outbid by a New York or
less Alexander he paid eighty million
dollars for the team so in ten years the
team went from being worth 10 million to
80 million okay now now here we go to 25
years later we finish I just wanted my
people they've heard me say it a lot the
1982 NBA Finals in America was on tape
delay it was it was the leading was
nothing there was nothing the way you
guys think about hockey right now this
was below that and it's important I'll
tell you why it's important and the
reason I jumped in twice now the two
million twenty the league you and I have
a similarity as I'm listening
it's just arbitrage it's seeing things
just enough time before somebody else
but that having the conviction and the
gumption to [ __ ] do something 100% so
so think about this in 1992 I get out
bid for 80 million
okay so 25 years later I don't get the
team so I'm building my company so I
build
that 25 years I grow my net worth from
10 million to almost 5 billion
okay that's good the Rockets go up for
sale again 25 years later - I come in
with the highest bid I was right there
most ever paid for sports franchise 2.2
billion so in 25 years the value of that
team goes from 80 million to 2.2 billion
and that's real dollars this isn't
monopoly money okay
you are the money you pay for it so tell
me were you were you a big basketball
fan
uh this is this is so unbelievable I sit
in the same seats today that I set in
for the last 25 years center court I I
was one of the this is so funny after I
bought the team I'm one of the thirty
longest season ticket holders of the
Rockets I love you in that amazing and
you know he's amazing it's literally
your hometown I'm gonna tell this story
in 31 years I'm gonna clip this be like
I was sitting Missy now I'm here and
some new person she's sitting in that
seat like I [ __ ] understand I would
kill my children for the New York Jets
you know and I you know what I would
sell my children for the Houston Texans
of Dallas Cowboys you like both those
teams know you want to own an NFL team
own an NFL team that's that's a superc
as a young young kid who was your
favorite team what you know what's kind
of funny is is was guys because baseball
was religion when you were a kid when I
was the biggest Astros buddy there was
there was Astros all over but but what
happened was they used to have the you
young guys don't know this but they
don't look like that y'all don't know
[ __ ] I don't know how bad we had go
ahead gentlemen couldn't even watch the
NFL team in Houston and you lived in
Galveston because it was the 50-mile
blackout rule so you didn't get because
I wanted you to come to the game because
I didn't sell out they couldn't sell
blast you out which they didn't sell
that's how the Raiders and cowboys and
Steelers became all people's fans
because when they would black you out
they would show you one of those three
teams and so in because Dallas was
betrayed because Dallas was the next
close
cysteine and all of a sudden remember
this when do you become a sports fan 9
10 years old so I'm 9 10 years old
that's when the Cowboys start playing
the Green Bay Packers and the ice bowls
and I'm watching them because the
Houston Oilers or Navy as somebody who's
in a market with two other basketball
teams in the state of Texas even though
it's a big state so I'm gonna give you I
have an idea for you that I'm gonna do
when I buy the Jets when I buy the Jets
because I hate the Giants more than
anything well not more than a Patriots
but I hate the Giants right when I buy
the Jets my core marketing strategy to
win the tri-state area is on every
single person's sixth birthday I'm gonna
send them a Jets Jersey and personalized
messages I think you should start
sending six-year-olds jerseys in San
Antonio and Dallas of rocket players why
in the hell did you tell me this on air
so I that I'm the smart [ __ ]
that came up with this you know what let
me be smart Tilly this is the greatest
tragic aim up with because I have good
ideas and because I can't execute all of
them I put them out for free so that I
can own the IP interesting right
Christina right right think about all
the smart [ __ ] like just getting a sense
of you right now by the way I'm gonna
say this publicly uh I'm not joking I
don't usually like I had no clue you
owned that or how like I don't know much
about a lot of stuff I just spend 100%
of my time on the consumer
I just don't know a lot of stuff I just
know what customers are doing at all
times that's why I don't know much so
other stuff that takes a lot of time so
this gets booked through email Matt put
us together but I know of you of course
and over the last week I've been with
some fancy different people you know
just like wheel movers and shakers I the
reason I was so excited to come in here
today is I basically live my life for
people to talk about me behind my back
the way the four people that I spoke to
in the last week about you talked about
you interesting that is interesting
I don't know if it was good or bad it
was very good it was very good no it was
very good because because what what is
interesting is I'm always fascinated by
people that actually know people
versus knowing of them interesting you
know my big game in life there's plenty
of people with the way I roll the
cursing the bravado the confidence the
Commission
especially if I'm putting pressure on
your business you're not gonna love me
but I care about what the people that
actually know me say about me and in
that group a couple them really know you
and like and are also very very close to
me so they're not gonna [ __ ] me it's
really cool I like that I appreciate
that
anyway so keep going well why'd you
write the book you know it's really
interesting about 18 months ago
HarperCollins called me and said hey and
we watch your television show
billion-dollar buyer we we we see you on
the other business shows and you always
had these tilman isms and these
one-liners and we've read all these
articles about you how you say oh I can
see a Burnout light bulb at one of my
restaurants from 40,000 feet and and
they said we'd like you to write a book
well I always thought somebody would say
we want you to write a life story book
and I said I can't do that until I'm
older because I'm still doing deals and
I want to rip some people's ass okay
yeah so they said no we want you do you
drive sale sir do you ever go Raj sale
do you could roll up on a garage sale
and try to buy something and for a
dollar
not another that zahra for you right not
as our as margaret garage sale yeah but
but did you i've when i was young i
apologize for interrupting but you said
rip somebody's ass and I'm like listen
like the the happy I'll give you a story
I was at the national sports card
convention I got to talk to you about
basketball cards before we leave like I
see a humongous arbitrage and sports
cards and you need to go all-in I'm
being dead serious with you on the
record I was at the National Sports card
convention in Chicago in in late July
this year I walked over to some guys
table bought a Wayne Gretzky rookie card
not in great condition for 220 bucks I
brought it back to my table priced it at
260 an hour later somebody came over and
bought it for 260 I swear on everything
that $40 arm meant more to me than all
50 trillion dollar deals I make every
day absolutely because that's what we do
that's like [ __ ] I can the deal ads
are for all the yeah it's
that's why I asked you about garages so
anyway the reason you don't want to
write a book is you still got a couple
moves in you and you don't want to put
it out there because the way that's how
you're gonna fly but so they just wanted
it in a silo and say talk about how you
made it what were your philosophies all
your Tillman isms and you know the
ninety nine ninety five five ruled there
are no spare you know ninety five
percent of everything we do is right
every day in business but look for the
five percent you do wrong and that's
what makes you better than everybody
else there are no spare customers okay
it's a competitive world and every one
of our businesses take no out of your
damn vocabulary you you're on a business
trip and it's 11:02 you hang up the
phone and and on a call and you call
down to order some breakfast and they
saw I'm sorry sir we don't serve
breakfast anymore and that's okay no
problem I don't need a waffle or or an
eggs benedict just throw a couple eggs
and a skillet and send them up scrambled
however is easy for you to do I'm sorry
sir we don't serve breakfast why are you
telling me no I didn't ask you for
anything special you're going to throw a
burger in the pan just throw me a couple
of eggs and take care of me B you're in
the hospitality business okay and you're
telling me no and everybody's in the
hospitality business no matter what they
do you take care of your customer okay
you take care of your customers it's no
different than we walk in and your
people meet us polite you put a welcome
up on the screen you come in here
everybody couldn't be can I get you some
water
tell me can can I do this for you you're
in the service business so why do you
want to be an ass and say no to somebody
when it's just as easy to say yes or
just given up the company's being run by
somebody who's not cuz these companies
get big and they hire somebody who
[ __ ] went to Harvard and [ __ ] work
the bane of McKinsey and they don't know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about
that's why Tillman I love my McKinsey
consultants when I see him I just love
them it's so funny you said that because
I have in this book consultants will
consult your ass right out of business
okay and I don't hire consultants you
know why because they've never [ __ ]
done anything unless I need I need a
report or something and I tell them what
I want him to say like that's what
Iraqis Brooke what the [ __ ] do stupid
I watch a lot of basketball I've got
ideas it's [ __ ] stupid cuz you know
what you know and what you don't know it
it's unbelievable that it's why I love
athletes when you really get to know
them it's really fascinating how they
talk about fans they've got whatever
variable no matter how you take it pro
and con what I see if you if you melt
every athlete what they really say when
they talk about fans is they just don't
know whether they say they're [ __ ]
or whether they love them they just
understand that they have no [ __ ]
idea
they have no context it's actually my
favorite thing that's going on in earth
right now we live in a judgment society
because of social and everybody has a
voice and because the way we've always
been judgmental that's how humans are
small little town somebody said Oh
Ruth's borscht is not as good like we've
always been right but but now we can see
the physical manifestation of it
but the reality is people are judging
people left and right without knowing
anything about the truth nobody knows
you nobody know and that's why when when
I have a good friends that'll say to me
you know I was over here and I was at a
bar and they were trashing your ass and
I'll say to him what do you know Tillman
42 no but that's what I heard you know
because people don't like people on top
okay and and and you're on top I'm on
top and and and I do think people though
we're getting a little nicer though I
think people now seem listen we respect
you or whatever macro anxiety in the
ecosystem and eventually that becomes
tiring and people going like the world
just absent flows it's not super
complicated you know too much so what
what was the breakthrough so I like the
story cuz I want to go back as I like
learning from storytelling and you're
doing a great job at it you know have to
pay back for an extra five that gives
you a mo what was the you have all these
great brands so I'm really excited to
dig in here a little bit because by the
way my entire company which were global
marketing company a thousand people big
business it's all a front
I'm building all this infrastructure to
do what you and I do at scale which is
one of the economy collapses I'm gonna
buy historic brands and refurbish them
and that's what I do and I was the first
person out there to start a platform and
saying like let me give you an example
so I go public in 1993 with what with
ten restaurants let you want and receive
food yeah
I'm making six million a year in e ba'da
and all of a sudden you wake up and
you're on the Nasdaq and you're worth a
hundred million dollars so over the next
few years I build restaurants and then I
then we hit a dip in in the late 90s
what that dip the tech dip okay market
the market did and it's also the stock
price went down yes
at the same time was just business
healthy though just my business was
healthy and you know this what your
stock does and the house nothing
happened
that's not a day with each other you
know just so much their numbers Dylan
wait a minute this is actually
completely confusing to me you were a
public CEO yes for how many years how
the [ __ ] did you deal with that [ __ ]
because I performed and oh [ __ ] and you
had to a little bit you're right you had
to tell these people on the earning call
who would like try to ticky tack you on
some [ __ ] and you're longer I got in
the richer I got I put up with less okay
but but you got Everage is a funny thing
no but but it's it's interesting because
my getify I get a board that like was
all in on you limit let me please first
off it when I took it public I owned a
hundred percent okay okay easy way to so
so it was mop board it was you it was my
I had a board but it was my board it was
yeah and and and if you keep vote for 50
percent you only have to have an outset
Audit Committee you don't even have to
have an outside board so you don't have
to have a compensation committee and all
that okay so so I basically controlled
the company for many many years but I
grew it from a thirty million dollar
company to when I took it private being
an opportunist you know X amount of
years later to a multi-billion dollar
company but but we we got off track
somewhere but what happened is don't
worry I realize but I realized I
realized that I could go buy somebody
and get rid of their GA and bring them
to Euston and keep the store operations
but not have all that overhead and so
over the next Russian because over the
next 20 years what I did was and I can
tell you every city that I shut down
somebody from Portland McCormick and
Schmidt's acog Oh chart houses home
offices were there and Martin's home
offices were there
in Laguna Beach it was Bubba Gump and
claim-jumper and I can just go from city
to city Minneapolis it was ocean air and
rain forests so I bought all these
companies and I just shut their office
down and consolidating in in Houston and
saved millions and millions and millions
on GA and and so I built this platform
and I bought all these companies right
and and rejuvinated them if they needed
it some of them weren't even screwed up
they were just screwed up public
companies but they were I bought
rainforests for 75 million dollars and
it was making 30 million a year and had
15 million in the bank but but their
stock had fallen cuz they're gross slow
down but it was a great company to buy
and back then everybody else was scared
private equity hadn't gotten into
consumer businesses yet and people that
are strategics wouldn't buy him because
I'm a CEO they might fire my ass if I
screw up well I said [ __ ] this I'll go
buy the world and took much money for us
you ate a few hundred million to
billions yep then what happened I
unstuck better keep going [ __ ]
okay so you built that up you build that
up you build that up and then in ten
well a lot of them happened after ten
okay but in oh wait no nine when the
crisis and every stock went down yeah I
went back and bought a hundred percent
of my company again yeah and today you
were liquid enough I was liquid enough
and knew had a financially engineer it
that's it and and today it's probably
truly the single largest one shareholder
company in America you know everybody's
got a one percent partner or this or
that it is 100 percent me and my family
and and four billion in revenues 700
million and even it's [ __ ] amazing so
it's been a good ride have you been
paying attack have you been paying it so
you're still actively running it [ __ ]
yeah else is gonna run I don't know I
mean you said APO you said yes 18 years
you took a private yes and then I'm
still listen I don't know [ __ ] about you
obvious I mean I know you're [ __ ] I
don't [ __ ] did you look at my [ __ ]
report card to me talk to me about this
are you paying attention to the
disruption that potential district is
something that's probably on your radar
especially the video
by the way at some point we'll have
dinner I can feel it already and I
really really need you to tell me the
war stories about the video game water
as a mom I love that but are you paying
attention to these you know virtual
kitchens are you because I'm very fat
you know this is early for me you're a
much deeper expertise but I think fast
casual and q sr have a looming potential
concern very similar to the way I felt
about retail 10 years ago around these
virtual kitchens and people building
brands on top of that infrastructure and
actually just being marketing companies
and doing last mile delivery at scale in
a decade is this on your mind I see all
of it and I think about all of it but
food to me is still a personal thing and
I just don't think your personal as an
you'll go somewhere no yes and how you
eat it and who prepared and or whatever
so I don't know that the the virtual
kitchen is it is it gonna ever work
so you're saying from you know maybe
from a fast food drive in infrastructure
that will disrupt it because that's a
mobile play but things that go a little
bit higher up where you're actually
going to it but we're gonna always like
it if you can if it helps you quicker
you know technology speeds its speed
beats okay but I still think that you
still want to touch and feel at the same
time it'll be interesting hold on let's
keep playing this cuz I'm passing about
your take touch and feel is in like I
have to talk to the place go to the
place that I talk about it that I
believe in and but I think on the
delivery front there's it's gonna be a
fascinating debate there is a there is a
delivery issue though and this is the
problem you've got all the foam delivery
companies they're all the water they're
all underwater I invested in one oh no I
wasn't dry i drowned
yeah you're dead because the problem is
is that it's expensive because of labor
costs today and a fuel cost and
everything else and then the delivery
companies want a 20% discount at least
or a little more a little less at the
restaurants don't make any money then
because that's our margin yep okay so
they're not happy we're not happy so I
really don't know
where it's going if you want to know the
truth that I agree with because that
infrastructure doesn't the drivers
aren't winning the restaurants aren't
winning the platforms are not waiting
that's dead I think that the next step
that's being built quietly right now
which is the infrastructure to make the
food at scale within one mile radius of
an enormous percentage of our society is
gonna be a totally different game I will
totally and once again we can all come
up with great ideas and this is gonna
work blue apron people we're gonna never
go out to dinner again they're gonna let
me ask you this do you
this is just a fun thing because you
know in ten years we'll watch this video
will will get a kick because the by the
way what I would know about you because
I'm listening for sure is 99% of people
don't play the way we play because
they're scared to lose no fear
I love losing and I mean it I actually
mean it I because that means I [ __ ] up
I deserve it I deserve it
I never blame anything else I did
something I did something wrong
full [ __ ] accountability nonetheless
do you believe I let me rephrase it do
you agree with this statement because I
think you may not which is amazing I
believe that in a decade there will be a
restaurant that looks like Shake Shack
that looks like you know chick-fil-a
that looks like fast fast fast or q sr
that actually has no locations but is a
billion dollar enterprise and sales of
their product on the framework of these
kitchens at scale around the world true
or false
possibly could happen we're gonna Ross
awesome now we have a fun dinner in ten
years
nope because I've even I have so many
brilliant I have so many brands in
Houston I've thought about building just
one kitchen and get everything go out of
there I get it okay but then your your
delivery pie is only gonna be so big
yeah unless you infrastructure at scale
listen I gotta run because I have a
public appearance but I'm [ __ ] pissed
because we haven't even started so we
need to hack this you how often are you
in Houston always no no I have a place
here in New York also I'm up here
depart some are you willing to do part
two with me on this absolutely
absolutely when's the book is the book
out the book came out yesterday I
ordered on Amazon person that's watching
buy this book shut up and listen shut up
and listen and and what's better than
you get that more than anybody right you
know what you know what's funny no
because because meaning I get it from
people saying no no no I understand that
because you want people to listen
because you know you have something to
say you know what's funny Tilman I'll be
very frank with you this is interesting
to me
mine would be like you know what my
title would be like hey I hope you
listen because if you actually do
something with what I'm saying something
good might happen you know to me I put
that's a long ass it's a long ass tile
but that's what you know for all the
things dyslexia you know you know for
all for all the things for all the
things Tilghman that I think have gone
well what have you there's an
interesting you you really won me over
on the eggs at 11:04 for some weird
reason no matter what I accomplished it
I [ __ ] plan on accomplishing there's
something about the consumer that I just
respect so uncomfortably more than what
I want for myself that it makes me go
there right I don't even I don't feel
all my accomplishments or all the
predictions and invest all the things
I've been right about still to this day
I think I have to earn oh hey please
consider I you know which is what and I
love where you went with it I know where
you went with it but my big thing
actually my big thing is the prayer that
they do something with it till men do
you know many people are watching or
listening to this right now who've come
across you over the last 30 or 40 years
who had the luxury of being in a meeting
or dinner with you where you said
something smart they built on top of it
they knew what to do but they didn't do
anything about it no but I people tell
me I know this I've had to learn ish
we're just talking words but people
listen
yeah listen dad I understand what I'm
talking about is the amount of for
example I'm gonna tell you right now
that you should buy a shitload of will
Chamberland Oscar Robinson that the
legends of the NBA are on the beginning
phases of
being similar to the Marvel Universe and
some of the most iconic 60s and 70s and
even early eighties superstars rookie
cards are about to 10x I know that to be
true okay don't tell everybody listening
to us Gary I want to know the best part
of why I keep doing this nobody takes
[ __ ] action well I will take some
action yes sir all right y'all kids on
my next meeting